[Music]
Innsbruck the self-styled capital of the
Alps is surrounded by mountains like a
natural rampart the city got its name
from a bridge over the river in at one
end is the medieval city center the
garden is dug or golden roof is one of
the main tourist sites it was built of
fire gilded copper tiles in the year
1500 BC so it's our landmark other high
medieval cities also have these Orioles
but this one is special as you can see
by the golden roof but it's not just the
roof the loggia itself is quite special
ah but meager with machine-gun golden
shingles or something quite
extraordinary for that time
the god mystical was built for the holy
roman emperor maximilian the first and
financed from the dowry of his wealthy
second wife all twenty-six hundred and
fifty-seven gilded tiles are the
originals
if you'd like to take a shingle with you
visit cafe mooning the oldest pastry
shop in tirol it features international
and regional baked goods including a
chewy sweet version of the golden tiles
[Music]
my brother came up with the idea for a
praline he said we've got to offer
something special from Innsbruck this
shingle was made of honey roasted almond
flakes pistachio marzipan and almond
nougat in three layers partially dipped
in dark chocolate another aspect of
emperor maximilian x' legacy is found in
the court church the black marbles
Cenotaph a tomb without the emperor's
remains surrounding it are 28 bronze
statues including historical figures and
maximillian's ancestors and relatives
each weighing up to two tons maximilian
himself commissioned the tomb but his
remains are interred near vienna i admit
that many memphis he tried boosting his
popularity using all the means at his
disposal at the time and left lasting
traces everywhere as a result you might
call him one of the first media stars of
his day along with all its imperial
splendour innsbruck also boasts some
world-class modern architecture in 2001
the Baggies of ski jump was remodeled by
the late british architect Zaha Hadid it
since become a city landmark Hadid was
also commissioned to create the four
stations of the hung a Bhagavan
funicular railway the futuristic
contours are a striking addition to the
skyline Theo tonin seemed so Adid
designed the stations to evoke our River
and the station's colors are supposed to
reflect the meltwater from the glaciers
that empty into the inn that's why they
have this greenish tinge gloomy kids
hatch it's only ten minutes on the
hoborg bond from the city centre to the
top station on the mountainside
then it takes another ten minutes by
cable car to reach the ski slopes this
is a paradise for winter sports into
occurs twice hosted the Winter Olympics
some 30,000 University students fuel a
youthful and creative attitude into
roles capital the endless store
association is a platform for the
region's artists and artisans the
selection changes every month designer
course it off a cliff
Innsbruck has a lot going on relative to
its size and it has a certain tradition
in arts and crafts and he lives for the
many students and people coming and
going have made it's a dynamic place
gourmets in search of typical Tyrolean
cuisine are best served with farmers
fair pastries and noodle specialties
locals often cook with regionally
sourced ingredients and that applies to
the national dish as well
Tyrolean Gustin is a classic main course
fried potatoes ball beef onions fried
eggs all ingredients you'd normally find
in a well-stocked kitchen and Tyrolean
crushed or filled pastries are even
tastier with the panoramic view of hinz
work shining under the Alpine Sun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]